can you explain to people out there what
more like this triangle of information
knowledge
and experience yeah how do they work
together yeah absolutely so
uh in the in in the intel world we're
always trying to find
intelligence the the equivalent of
intelligence in the
in the everyday world is knowledge right
knowledge of things that
are essentially uh forbidden for you to
know that's
intelligence intelligence is really
secrets that you're not supposed to know
knowledge that you're not supposed to
know is the closest thing that we have
in the everyday world
the way that we get there you know it
meaning it's truth
uh no you're not allowed to know it
because it's a secret
that's that's what intel is right right
so knowledge
is essentially uh the equivalent of that
because
except that your it's knowledge that you
otherwise wouldn't have known to be true
okay got it there you go absolutely so
the cycle the cycle that we're taught is
a triangle
and at the top of the triangle is
information everybody has
access to information and information is
everywhere everywhere
we talked about sensors when we talked
about the myers-briggs personality types
you can use your five senses to pick up
information from anywhere
what you see what you hear what you read
what you taste whatever right
information is everywhere but not all
information is true not all information
is valid
not all information is trustworthy you
know some information is straight up
malicious
right so information is not enough on
its own
it has to be refined into knowledge
the way that you refine that information
into knowledge is through multiple
different tools you can
you can find multiple sources that
corroborate information
so if if can you define knowledge
sure so knowledge is
uh is
stronger evidence-based information
that has the predominant uh
predominantly is
is probable to be true that is knowledge
okay
right if it has a low probability of
being true it's not really knowledge
okay if it's not uh if it's not a if it
isn't heavier weightier
than information then it's not knowledge
either right so
knowledge is something that gives you an
advantage knowledge is a fundamental
truth
or a high probability of being true that
you can use to leverage yourself
like knowing i don't know like knowing
that your your car is
currently in the parking lot right now
you have knowledge of the location of
your vehicle
right that you may not have you don't
have that knowledge right now okay right
you have information because you know
i'm here and therefore my car must be
here right okay
where is it parked is it got it here
across the street or somewhere else uh
let me give you an example that comes
out of
covet headlines right china has said
that their covid vaccine
has a 79 efficacy rate
right so it's 79 effective according to
efficacy
the uae who is also running a parallel
test
of the same vaccine has claimed that it
has an
89 efficacy rate
china who created the vaccine says it's
79 the emiratis say that it's 89
that's a 10 discrepancy nobody
has filled in the gap as to how these
two countries using the same vaccine
have reached such different conclusions
right
that information if somebody were to
read
a headline that said that the chinese
whatever it's called corona sino vaccine
or something whatever it's called
this is the chinese vaccine is 89
effective
that's not really true right that's just
one source of information from one
country
that has said that once you kind of
continue researching
continue collecting more information you
see that another country who actually
developed it
has said something different so now you
have the knowledge to know you can't
trust either number
right you see how that works yes
otherwise you would just be moving
forward with information okay
so that's that is the difference between
information and knowledge what you see
what you hear what you think
isn't always true like there's more
information to be gathered
the more information you gather that
that vets and validates something to be
true the
closer it is getting to being
knowledgeable got it so once you have
multiple pieces of information that
confirm that something is true
now you have knowledge knowledge is a
tool knowledge is a genuine advantage
tons of people out there making
decisions based on information they're
making the wrong decision
wasting money wasting time right making
mistakes you make your decisions based
off of knowledge
you don't waste your money you don't
waste your time you don't make mistakes
that's why knowledge is like
intelligence
in the intel world cia doesn't want to
invade a country or launch some
you know launch some offensive because
of bad information
so they're going to vet it they're going
to test it they're going to make sure
it's true
intel true knowledge before they take
action
okay so we need to do the same thing if
if we do the same thing
we have a significant advantage over all
the other people around us who are just
acting on information
right once you have that knowledge you
take action once you take action what
does action do
you gain new experience from the action
that you're taking
right so you using that same
china uae study on how effective is the
chinese corona vaccine
right there's plenty of people there's a
whole country the entire country of uae
and all the foreign residents in that
country were mandated to take the
vaccine
as soon as it came out in like december
government mandate
pushed down by the royal crown prince
right
to me that's crazy but now
three months later we look back on that
and we're like how
immune how vaccinated is that country
really
is it 89 or is it 79 or is it something
else altogether
[Music]
we have the knowledge now to know not to
take that vaccine
and not to trust the numbers about that
vaccine from either of those countries
or from any other country that's
probably going to report it but instead
we're going to pay attention to the
discrepancies in
each of their reports that's going to
give us experience
experience that we can use to collect
more information
right what are the other countries that
are using the vaccine what are their
reports
now we have now we have a whole
different range of questions that we can
ask
how did uae test this how did china test
this how will paraguay test this how
will
somalia test this right like all the
countries that are involved we now know
the right questions to ask to gain
information that goes back to the top of
the triangle
right and the more information that we
gain that confirms
validates and true and proves to be true
the more knowledge we get the better the
questions can be
and there we have what we call an intel
triangle
what everyday people what i teach as a
knowledge triangle
right right and it's a self-fulfilling
like it's a self
a feedback loop that you keep using to
refine yourself over and over again
right better better information is never
available information is garbage
everywhere
you can always use garbage information
to find
true knowledge though knowledge gives
you true experience which is going to
give you more
garbage information but you can cull
through the garbage information to find
more true knowledge instead people are
trying to find true information
you're never going to find it no but the
thing about information is that
it's just so it's it's clickbait
clickbait is is just
the slew of crazy you know headlines
that are out there that people love to
share and get clicks and get comments on
and respond to it which
essentially just makes more money yeah
exactly there's a push-pull relationship
right
information is always going to be pushed
it's always going to be pushed
out pushed to you push to everybody
because there's there's
you information is used to make money
like you said click bait
advertising attention dollars right
ratings whatever it might be so there's
always an incentive to push out
information
the only way you're going to get
knowledge is to pull you have to pull
from the information the the pieces
that corroborate the pieces that
validate the pieces that
are true that vet right pull those out
and now you have a much smaller pool of
genuine knowledge
what i do with everyday spy the whole
the whole core of
my business method is to basically
create knowledge and share that
knowledge with corporate clients with
individual clients with training
personnel like with other intel services
right anybody who employs me
my goal is to cull through information
create knowledge
teach people how to cull through
information create knowledge because the
knowledge is the real value
the information is just a distraction
what kind of people
can't contract you to do this kind of
work um so i've actually served in uae
i actually had a contract with the uae
government really to go out there and
teach them how to do this
because they had where they had learned
before was not
accurate or valid so i've worked for
foreign governments i've worked for
usdod i've worked for major
military contractors here in the united
states really i've got silicon
i'm currently i'm sending out a proposal
today it's a silicon valley
like massive companies out there that
like ndas but
that that have an interest in the same
the same skill set
there's a huge demand out there for
being able to
keep up with conflicting information
and making something valuable out of it
because there's so much
information out there it's it's the same
processes like
making iron ore you got to dig a lot of
dirt
and pull a lot of iron ore out before
you can smelt it into iron it's the same
process happening now there's a ton of
information you got to dig through a lot
of information have a process to pull
out the little bits
that are ore and smelt them into
something useful like iron yeah i mean
that's a it seems like a huge
problem that would be great if we could
solve it
with with people just digesting
tidbits of information and not getting
the full picture right and it's what
what kills me is that it's not
uh the people who recognize the problem
the more money they are worth the more
net worth an individual has
what i have seen the more aware of the
problem they are
because the more net worth you have the
more money you're investing
the more you're trying to use money to
make money right so you see it as a big
problem because you want to make the
right investment
because you don't want to waste your
money right
your money is your biggest asset right
but that's only like two percent of the
population
i think the top 10 of income earners
earn
190 000 or more really that's not that
much money
right that means 90 of the country earns
less than
and ninety thousand dollars a year the
less money you make
the less you think information is a
problem because you're not
investing your money to try to make more
money you're just trying to survive day
to day
right you go to work you work eight
hours you come home
every week or every two weeks you get
your paycheck you spend almost all of
your paycheck
on food day care basic entertainment
needs whatever else you're not saving it
you're not investing it
so you're looking for information to
just be a distraction to be an escape
from the humdrum routine of life right
so they don't see that as a problem so
there's nothing i can do for them
but the people who recognize that people
have enough wealth or enough insight to
realize like
information is a problem and where
there's a problem
there's a hidden advantage because the
companies that can solve the problem
first
will make the most money the investors
who can solve the money to solve the
problem first
will make the best investments like the
countries that can solve the problem
first will have the most security